many of you may have seen what happened
last night on this show and
um I have concerns that we had yay
Fuentes and Milo on the show a lot of
people messaged me beforehand saying why
are you having them on what they're
using you they have an agenda and I'm
and who's they who's they no no but
listen listen they say they say uh they
as in general people messaging me
they're using you Tim they're using you
and I said for all of them why do you
think people come on this show do you
think they're coming on because they
love me and they want to hold my hand
and smile and look at my face or do you
think they're trying to promote a book
do you think they're trying to get a
message out they're trying to promote
their Twitter accounts they have ideas
they want to share of course everyone's
using everybody I have guests on so we
can make an interesting show it's our
business they come on because it's an
opportunity for them to to share or sell
or whatever I thought we were friends I
think again that's that's my we're only
having you on because you make us laugh
okay I guess I'm a clown
[Laughter]
so here's here's what I want to say
because um right now there's a lot of
stories you know uh Trump is being told
that he's got to denounce these guys
there was a story that popped up on Fox
Fox 5 Kanye West spotted in Frederick
after storming off of podcast
here's the potential scenario to be fair
the scenario is they abruptly left the
show they were on it yay didn't like
that I was not agreeing with him or that
I was pushing back in any capacity got
up and stormed off Milo and Nick working
for yay wouldn't stick around and left
immediately they called a charter
company to schedule a private plane who
was very very they were very lucky that
a hot crew it's what they're on the
ground ready to go was available nearby
and was able to then dispatch a plane to
Frederick that they could then get into
within a couple hours notice entirely
possible my personal opinion
that sounds really really crazy if
that's the case so when I when when they
stormed off the show my my first thought
was that
um like okay you start off the show then
we talked about it and I said it was the
perfect thing to do if you want to
generate press there's a story going
around that Donald Trump met with Nick
Fuentes and anti-sema anti-semite white
supremacist that was all last week first
day first thing this week we have this
show and I think it was the first thing
Nick said on the show was that something
about it isn't it really them and then
immediately yay gets up and walks out
downstairs smile on his face eating
cookies apparently uh one of our one of
our guys here said that when they were
leaving he said something like I came to
the show got what I needed now I'm done
I'm leaving and so that made me wonder
about what was the goal it's possible
maybe I'm just thinking too much into it
that Milo wanted revenge on Trump Milo
was quoted as saying he invited Nick
because he knew Trump would mishandle it
in the Press he wanted to make Trump's
life Trump's life miserable Trump is
mishandling in the press the first thing
out of uh I believe it was the first
thing out of out of Nick's mouth was but
isn't it them and then yay leaves right
around the half an hour mark when we're
at a hundred thousand concurrent viewers
and that said to me they had to have
planned this then I saw the video of
them going to the Frederick airport
boarding a what appears to be a super
mid private jet right after the show
within a few hours and I was like how
did they Charter a private jet that fast
it is entirely possible they did I know
where the jet originated we did some
sleuthing to figure it out what happened
was about a half an hour's flight time
away a hot crew uh this is what I'm told
it is entirely possible these are by the
experts in the in the private Aviation a
hot crew was available it would or say
I'm sorry what they said was a plane
nearby flew to Frederick
landed for about an hour and then
departed with them it is entirely
possible that they happened upon what's
called a hot crew that's what they said
meaning there were people on the ground
working ready to take off but for no but
for no reason the plane was not being
used yay is a very powerful wealthy
individual perhaps he knows somebody and
someone has his back it's interesting
considering everything's been saying
about how they're trying to arrest him
and shut him down and silence him and
censor him but apparently he was able to
get within two hours of notice a super
mid private jet to fly from here to Los
Angeles with a crew active
I I I I don't know what happened but to
me it sounds staged it sounded like they
knew in advance they'd be leaving at
least yay may have because that's that's
not the vibe I got I got that they seem
very genuine when they were here I I
know Milo I mean he's a gen I mean he's
a zany dude but like he's looking for
Redemption that's his path right now and
Kanye is grasping at straws to try and
find someone to help him and Nick was so
kind the entire time he was here like
I've heard stuff about him I've seen him
say stuff online out of context that's
racist but when you see him eyes to eyes
like the guy is looking for friends like
he doesn't probably has been lived in an
environment where he didn't have a lot
of friends so when you what happened was
you and Kanye were going back and forth
and kind of interrupting each other you
mentioned at one point Tim you were
holding your finger up and before you
want to jump in and he was on the show
and he's like you you want to say
something go for it before the show yeah
and even so when the show started it his
demeanor changed so you guys were kind
of had an agreement like we're gonna
kind of talk over each other we're gonna
flow but then when Nick chimed in and
you interrupted Nick Kanye's face
dropped and then he got out he was like
that's you crossed the line when you
throw up me that's okay you're up Nick
I'm out before the show when we're doing
pre-show and setting up it was so
different
Kanye said yay I'm sorry said few things
I pushed back and he just had a smile on
his face and he's like nodding along
like whatever the show comes on
and all of a sudden he's like we went to
Trump's dinner I was invited first I
called Milo so anyway let's talk about
anti-Semitism and I'm like whoa like we
were just talking before the show you
know what happened the first article no
he knew what the article was we had the
article pulled up pre-show he mentioned
Pence he asked Fuentes about Pence and
what Trump I said is that we'll we'll
use this story to launch the dinner and
the controversy caused by it and I'll
ask you about how this dinner came to be
what do you think about it what happened
with it and then what is yay 24 and I
was like who am I kidding we're gonna
get into the anti-Semitism stuff I'm
gonna push back here's how it'll play
out like I'm gonna if you guys want to
say something I'm gonna put my hand up
and let you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
talk about this and they're like of
course no problem absolutely fine and
then as soon as the show started all of
a sudden it was like oh how dare you
bring up this article oh my here's what
I don't understand about that dinner
that doesn't make sense to me you do not
get a plus three to meet with the
president I don't care who you are that
it's not Piers Morgan had a piece today
that he you know he won The Apprentice
he was I think the first winner of the
Celebrity Apprentice he was interviewing
Trump at Mar-A-Lago the Secret Service
you know basically gives you an anal
swab before we're going to meet a former
president especially if we're dealing at
Mar-A-Lago which not that long ago was
rated because there were concerns about
things that are classified whatever top
secret so on and so forth I don't
understand how if you're running for
president and this is the scenario in
your home you're going to have dinner
with someone anyone and be like oh yeah
you know bring bring your buddies and
not be paranoid even just for security
reasons who are these people are they
spies are they so on and so forth I
don't understand that we we struggle
with this
here when we're when we're bringing
people in
we have to be we have some this big
long-winded email about who's allowed
here what this means yeah invited by you
stuff like that now I wouldn't say it's
like we're that strict where we but
you're not the president exactly you're
not a former president it's absolutely
Beggars believe and the other thing is
like Jake wieger had a tweet about like
this isn't a surprise this is who Trump
hangs out with white supremacists it's
like when someone's the president you
know exactly what they're hanging out
with you know every minute of their day
what they're having for dinner and so on
and so forth It's not a big secret their
their schedule is very public and very
known and it's it's a very big deal this
is the president of the United States in
this case the foreign president United
States so what Trump is saying does not
uh cut ice with me and what else is
crazier to me in all seriousness his
daughter converted to Judaism right so
this is something that obviously and I
think one of his other kids married a
Jewish woman so he the joke is like
what's the difference between a New York
Times reader and Donald Trump Donald
Trump's grandchildren are going to be
Jewish it's like if he has this in his
family for him to be like well oops I
didn't know so that's just confusing
you think he just trusted Kanye and was
like if you want to bring whoever but
why would you trust but he just tried I
think first of all he has this this
boner for celebrities that is really
demented because that explains why he's
endorsing Dr Oz who believe Justice
Millet who is for Trans kids surgeries
you know who had the whole laundry list
of like you know very Lefty ideas
Herschel Walker who's just a football
star uh for Senate like in the The Love
Affair Donald Trump has for people who
are blue checks is demented I want to I
think Ian's right about one thing that
this guy's looking for friends
I can't speak to the things that I any
of them have said in the past like what
I should say is like obviously they've
said deplorable things testable things
but what I genuinely believe is
we had Milo on this show a couple weeks
ago and he talked about supporting Trump
he talked about vengeance he wasn't
talking about this stuff it was it was
his Focus was different then he gets
involved with with yay brings in Fuentes
and all of a sudden this is like a
particular component of his his career
or his personality what I think happens
is when you cancel people they go in the
only Direction they can wait I I can
disagree because I have receipts from
Milo because when this all came out I
wrote a book about this there's a
chapter up Milo in my book and then you
write I think Milo is very very Charming
he's very very witty he's certainly very
intelligent and of all the people who
got canceled the reason he got canceled
I think was one of the more BS reasons
uh he was the victim of childhood abuse
he spoke out about in a kind of
tongue-in-cheek manner I don't begrudge
anyone who's suffered through something
like that how they should deal with the
situation and he was basically saying
things like okay you know this is
something that I'm he's kind of
rationalizing like I'm glad this
happened to me at a young age as opposed
to being like holy crap you know I got
my innocence taken up taken from me at a
time when it shouldn't have so I think
the fact that that key was just like you
know get out like everything's ruined
for you because of something that had
been done to him where he was innocent
as a kid or teenager I thought was
really kind of over the top and clearly
it was like Al Capone going to jail
because of income taxes it really wasn't
income tax they're just looking for an
excuse to get rid of him but he did an
article a couple years ago with the
Jewish Journal because when this all
came out I'm like I thought Milo was
Jewish because I remember this being a
thing at the time when he pushed back
about the Nazis about this I sent the
hold on let me pull it up I got the uh
DM here and here's the article from the
Jewish Journal this is from 2019 uh and
he was talking about this then because
this is with the Jewish journal and he
had said I'm quoting Milo here
um let me get out he goes he thinks the
Jewish Community the Jewish Lobby would
be well served to not throw a gas gasket
every time someone throws out what it
may appear to be an anti-semitic Trope
and he says this is quoting Milo just
like I don't like left-wing political
correctness about women in blacks and
Muslims I don't like right-wing
political correctness about Jews in
Israel so and he said people claim that
really stupid things are antisemitic
that are not really anti-semitic or they
make more of a fuss about it than they
need to so at a certain point he has
been addressing this at least 2019 so
three years ago what I mean to say is uh
if these guys were given an opportunity
if if some if some obviously it would
never happen but if you went to any one
of these guys and said we want you to be
a brand ambassador for a big company to
make you a lot of money but you got to
stay away from these subjects they'd say
yes
yeah probably I think what happens is
when
people get love bombed
you'll get somebody who like starts
getting a bunch of tweets where they're
like hey I like what you're saying keep
saying more of it and then they're going
to start feeling good they're going to
be like Oh I'm getting all this
attention building followers and then
some people are just gonna say like this
these are people supporting me and I'm
gonna side with them but there's an
inverse to that when you ban someone and
they have nowhere to go and they can't
get Redemption they will go to whoever
is willing to accept them and on top of
just the love bombs it's the financial
incentive because if people are getting
paid because they have a following now
they're getting ad revenue or they're
getting direct subscriptions no matter
what they're saying if they're saying
really cruel evil things and they're
getting paid for it
um that's free speech but also that can
incentivize the continuation of the
behavior and it's kind of tough to dig
out especially if you get canceled
you're like well the only people that
pay me are these people and they only
watch me because of this content so
let's do more of that when you get
canceled when you get censored you get
sent off to the Far Corners of the
internet where a lot of people get
radicalized and people need to
understand and bad ideas need to be
fought with good ideas and we don't have
this battle of ideas we never had this
battle of ideas mainly because of
centralized controllers big Tech
intervening and saying no we don't like
what you're saying we don't like your
political stance be gone you're and then
those ideas are never routinely
challenged routinely questioned uh
there's no pushback against them and
only in places where they fester and
grow are are these kind of larger
elements that that again never see the
light of public day and I and I think
this is why when you need to debate we
need to argue we need to of course
create Steelman arguments and a question
and debate everything this is another
takeaway I had from last night I love
the YouTube as a as a platform I've
Loved this in Steve Chen and Chad Hurley
built the thing and the third guy who I
don't know the name of Sergeant uh and
it but last night conversation was not a
conversation for YouTube in its current
state if you guys want to fix up your
terms of service into a more free speech
oriented thing it would be but when we
have people on that there's a chance
they might violate the terms of service
platform we got to go to another
platform because we need to let those
guys speak those people need to speak
and then let them because if Kanye had
went on for 30 minutes and then Nick
responded for 20 minutes and they said
all sorts of offensive things that
YouTube would have stopped we'd have a
chance to rebut and talk about it and
come to some sort of consensus that
ideally we would all come out of better
people from thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time